so what's happening today again I guess
the focus still on Don bass and what's
to come potentially in the next few days
yeah I think it was fun to see that
we're in the end stages of the battle
for several Donetsk um the Russians have
effectively got control of the city now
they certainly have control of all of
the residential areas there are still
Ukrainian troops holding out and they'll
still be fighting that we'll carry on
there they're currently based in a
chemical plant which is in the center of
the town and I think we're going to see
a rerun something very similar to what
we saw in mariopol which is that the
Russians gained control of the city
relatively quickly but the ukrainians
were able to hold a defensive position
in the steel plant for quite a long time
what is of concern though again in
severeign
plant has also got several hundreds
civilians that are taking cover in the
bomb shelters there obviously there's a
huge risk to them we've already seen
that Russian shelling of the area has
caused a fire in the chemical plant so
there's some real concern there
um what I think we'll start to see over
the over the next few days is that the
Russians will consolidate their control
of several Donetsk and although they may
wish to push on I think they'll find
that very difficult to do so militarily
they've spent a lot of men and equipment
on trying to take hold of several
Donetsk you know the battle's raged
backwards and forwards for a while now
and really they're going to need to take
a tactical pause to try and refit and
recuperate and reconstitute before
they're really able to make any further
movement so I think we'll see one last
burst in several Donetsk and then things
will become slightly quieter for a week
or two
what does this mean for The Wider region
I'm thinking specifically maybe her son
we know that was that fell to the
Russians quite early on
yeah so the battle of severeign
but this isn't because the town is
militarily that important it's mostly
symbolic it was the last major city in
lahance region that Ukraine wanted to be
able to hold on to really what
strategically important militarily and
particularly to Ukraine is the south
west where we've got Odessa which is a
major port the securing of Odessa is
absolutely vital to the long-term
security of Ukraine it's key export
route and they'll also be looking not
just to maintain control of it but
they'll be looking to make sure that it
isn't damaged so what that means is that
they want to keep the level of the
fighting well to the east in and around
Kirsten and in fact even as the battles
raged with severogenetsk the ukrainians
have actually been fighting very hard
around Kirsten and have made some small
advances there and I think this is
really key here because the ukrainians
have often been seen to be being on the
defensive but actually I think we're
going to start to see them try and work
out how they can move on the offensive
when and what conditions are required to
enable that and the key Focus for that
will be in and around Curson meanwhile
the Russians there aim really is to try
and you know consolidate their hold of
luhanskin further Donetsk and they'll be
looking to move west from severeign and
clear up that Salient there they're
really going to struggle because the
ukrainians as we've seen previously in
and around is zoom to the north are
still unbeaten there and really any
Russian movement further west and
severity Nets could be really quite
threatened so again I think we'll see
most of the fighting will take place
down here in the southwest
um ukrainians again calling for Western
support what do they want yeah so
there's you know kind of a couple of
facets to this so uh whilst they're
holding the line if you like they're
going to be looking at where the next
wave of their forces is going to come
from and it's clear they're going to
have to have Western provided kit and
Equipment the West has already promised
you know significant levels but the
ukrainians are going to need support
that needs to be delivered quickly and
efficiently and they also are going to
need quite a significant training burden
to make sure that their troops are able
to use this as we've seen ammunition has
been being used up very very quickly uh
Western supplied kit will need to come
with plentiful supplies of ammunition
um and then they're also going to need
support to make sure they can carry on
maintaining that kit and equipment and
then just as this battle perhaps becomes
less kinetic and it becomes harder to
see who exactly is gaining the upper
hand what Ukraine is going to really
need is is a measure of resolve that
this Western kitten equipment is going
to keep being supplied as this contest
carries on throughout the rest of the
year